Good morning, YouTube. Professor Tang
here um with another
video update on the situation in the
Middle East.
I wanted to originally do this talk next
week because I wanted to get a haircut
this weekend and surprise everyone. Um
but uh on Twitter, many of you um have
been clamoring for the next edition in
this series. So here we are.
In my last video, I discussed how Isaac
Newton built the intellectual
foundations for Christian Zionism, which
is driving American Middle East policy
today.
And today I want to explain to you why
Christian Zionism is such a powerful
force in the world.
Um, as you know, Nanyahu is visiting
Washington this week, meeting with
senior lawmakers, including with
President Donald Trump in the White
House.
And um this most definitely signals that
um Israel and the United States will
resume air strikes against
Iran and we will see an increase in the
escalation ladder uh in this war in the
Middle East. So why is this happening?
And it's happening because there are
four major factions in this anti-Iran
coal coalition
that's driving uh this war. The first
faction in this coalition of course are
the Christian Zionists who are trying to
achieve biblical prophecy. Um then you
have the Zionists who want to achieve
the greater Israel project which they
believe is a promised land um that
Yahweh gave to the Israelite people as
part of the covenant together. And this
is made explicit in the Bible.
The third faction um is the global
financial elite, Wall Street, city of
London. Um because for them, if they're
able to control Iran, the shirt of
Hummus, they're able to control not only
the vast oil reserves of Iran, but also
global trade, thus negating uh the
bricks project, thus negating China's
silk and road uh project.
Then you have the um American Empire,
the mo military industrial complex, the
deep state, whatever you want to call
these people, but they are first and
foremost interested in maintaining
American hijgemony. Um and if they're
able to control the entire Middle East,
then they will be able to maintain this
unipolar world.
Now, when I say that these four factions
are working together, you may think that
they are in a dark smoke filled room in
an underground bunker in Washington DC
somewhere. And that's how that's not
what and that is not what's happening.
Um, in fact, it's entirely possible they
don't even talk to each other. Um, so
let me you let me give you a metaphor to
explain to you how these four groups are
working together. Let's just say that
there's a mountain somewhere and on this
mountain uh people believe that God
lives on this mountain.
Now the Christian Zionists
want to build a road
um to this mountaintop in order to be
with God. Unfortunately, there are
people who live on this mountain. They
need to be exterminated.
A war has to be fought. But it's all for
the greater good because
they will be able to be with God. Um the
Zionists are involved because God um and
the Zionists know each other from
history. And so the Christian Zionists
need the Zionist involved in this
project. They really see the Zionist as
a ritual sacrifice in order to win favor
with with God. And the Christian
Zionists are involved with building this
world because
they're they see the Christian Zionist
as a useful tool in order to be with
their true God. And so when they reach
the mountain top then um their real god
will recognize their faith and kill and
kill the Christian Zionist.
So it's a cynical partnership between
the Christian Zionist and the Zionist
and they both need need each other for
now until they reach the mountain top.
Then you have the global financial elite
and these people are opportunists.
They're speculators. They are first and
foremost interested in generating more
wealth for themselves and their clients.
They themselves have no ideas. They
themselves have no real vision for the
world. They just want to make more
money. And in the energy and the
commitment in the faith of the Christian
Zionist and the Zionist, they see an
opportunity to monetize this faith. If
the Christian designers and designers
are working hard to build this road to
the mountain top then they can provide
financing for this road also when this
road is built they can start to collect
toll booths right so that's why they're
involved because they see this as a
money-making opportunity for them
they're only interested in making money
uh these people Wall Street Steve London
they're so wealthy because all they care
about is money In fact, for the right
price, they'd be perfectly willing to
sell their own children. Okay, that's
who these people are. Then you have the
American Empire. In the American Empire,
it's important to understand that these
are first and foremost bureaucrats. Um,
they have really cushy jobs sitting in
office somewhere pretending to work and
they need to justify their existence.
um they need to explain why they have
trillions of dollars in um in their
budget. And so this Christian Zionist
Zionist project to reach the mountain on
top provides the justification. they can
say, "Okay, well, you know what? If
these Christian Zionists, these
Zionists, if they're the ones who are
going to go and lobby the politicians
and bribe the politicians and pressure
the politicians to build this road, then
we'll say that we'll provide milit
military protection um in order to just
like our existence." Okay. So, um,
they're trying to do as little work as
possible in order to maintain their very
cushy jobs sitting somewhere in an air
condition office and that's it. Now,
that's the structure of their
relationship with each other. They're
all interested in reaching that mountain
top for different reasons. But once I
but once they reach that mountain top,
then they'll have their disagreements.
and how to reach that mountain top they
won't be aligned with. So the example
here is that the Christian Zionists and
the Zionists are very much interested in
using ground troops to force regime
change in Iran. Um the financiers and
the empire they're riskadverse. So they
really don't want to use ground troops.
um they want to achieve regime change
slowly, steadily in a um in a in a in a
way that contains risk. And so there's
going to be that disagreement about
whether or not to use ground troops. In
the end, I think the Christian Zionist
and the Zionist will win out. So let me
explain to you why
um let me explain to you using game
theory why the Christian Zionists are
the dominant power in this relationship
even though the financial financial
control of money and even though the
American empire controls the
armoraments.
So here let me introduce to you the
universal law of game theory. Once you
master this formula, once you truly
understand the ramifications,
uh the nuances, the subtleties of this
law, then you will have a much more
clear uh and deeper understanding of how
the world works. Okay? And this formula,
it's very simple. Um it goes like this.
If you look at game theories, all games,
the people who always win the game, they
win because
of this formula, which is mass
times energy
times coordination.
All right? So uh mass is just the number
of people um times energy which is the
level of motivation of these people
times coordination which is the ability
of these people to work together to
achieve their end.
Um some things to keep in mind about
this formula. First of all the different
factors are not weighted equally. So
coordination is the most important
factor and it's weighted at least three
times as much as mass. Then you have
energy. Um and energy is sec is what's
second most important and it's weighted
uh twice as much as mass. And um
depending and you know different
depending on the game the weightings can
be different but please please keep this
in mind. Coordination is what really
matters followed by energy followed
ultimately by mass. So if I explain
that, let me explain to you what each
term means and how we can measure each
factor to get a more mathematical
understanding of this formula.
Mass is just the number of people
involved.
But um what's important to measure is
their cohesion, how much they like each
other, how much they're willing to work
together. So for example
um you look at Japan and China, Japan
has much more cohesive society than
China. So in terms of mass, Japan is
actually stronger than China even though
China has 10 times or five times as many
people as Japan. Then you look at um
energy. Energy is level of motivation.
And usually when we think of energy, we
think of physical energy. But actually
in this formula, it's mental energy that
really matters because if you think
about it, it's mental energy that is the
most um uh expensive. And so you need
the most amount of motivation in order
to achieve mental energy. So let me give
you an example of this. Um let's just
say there are two people. The first
person, he's digging a hole in the
ground for 12 hours a day for a whole
year. Then you have another person who
every day is seeking to improve himself.
So he's constantly in the process of
self-reflection, writing down his the
ways that he can improve and creating a
strategy, a formula for how he can
improve himself. Well, according to this
formula, the second person is expending
much more energy than the first person.
Even though if we just look at it, it
seems like the it's the first person
that's doing all the work. The second
person just sitting around all day just
thinking. And the reason why is
in the world, the three hardest words to
say for a human being is I am wrong. To
say I'm wrong is to negate yourself, to
negate your ego, to admit that you have
failings. To say you are wrong is also
to commit to a policy of
self-improvement, self-change.
It's also tremendous loss of faith to
say I'm wrong before your peers. You
lower your status. Um you lose face. And
that and that's why um people who are
more energetic, who are more motivated,
they are much more open to change.
They're much more willing to accept
their limitations. They're much more
willing to commit to self-improvement.
So energy is a measure of motivation.
And we can measure motivation by a
group's openness to accepting its
limitations, its failings. Okay. So
that's idea of energy.
Then the third aspect of this formula is
any of coordination and coordination can
be divided into two different um two
different types. The first type is
conscious coordination. Second type is
subconscious coordination. Conscious
coordination is when you're led by
someone. Could be a leader. It could be
a bureaucracy. It could be a patriarch.
Subconscious coordination is when
there's no
clear leader or clear direction. people
just subconsciously
work together. Um it's almost like a
dance
and all the two subconscious
coordination is the most the more
powerful.
Um when people get together and they
sort of conspire together that leads to
all sorts of problems. You don't want
conspiracies. You don't want open
conspiracies. So let me explain to you
why opening conspiracies or secret
conspiracies are bad policy. Okay. Um
the first reason is
um
it's really hard to maintain the secrecy
of conspiracy. Eventually what's going
to leak out that these people are
conspiring together. And if word leaks
out that these people are conspiring
together that forces other people to
conspire together in this game. So um if
you are
conspiring together, you have to keep it
secret in order to maintain your
advantage. It's very very hard to keep
it secret. In fact, you probably waste
more time and energy keeping a secret
than you do in actually trying to
implement your conspiracy. Okay, so
that's the first reason why conspiracies
are not a good idea. Second reason is um
in most games conspiracies are illegal.
It's considered cheating. Um, so you
lose possible deniability when you are
conspiring together and when you're
keeping notes and when you're meeting in
a room together and plotting together.
The third reason is the most important.
Okay. The third reason why you don't
want to conspire together is everyone
has an ego. Everyone is trying to
maximize his or her self-interest in a
conspiracy and that immediately leads to
friction, conflict, debate. Um so
this creates friction in the
relationship. So subconscious
uh coordination is much more powerful
than conscious coordination. It allows
for frictionless cooperation
and allows for possible deniability and
allows for secrecy. So, examples of
subconscious coordination are families,
um, ethnicities,
um, religions. Okay. So,
>> so having said that, okay, having
presented this formula, mass times
energy times coordination,
I want to now
um give you some examples to understand
why this formula works. Okay, so let's
just say we're playing individual games.
Well, if we're playing an individual
game, one versus one, then the formula
breaks the formula is like this. mass
becomes one, coordination becomes one.
So we're only left with energy. So what
this formula is telling us that in an
individual player game, the person who
is most motivated, the person who is
most willing to commit to
self-improvement will win this game. And
the idea of constant self-improvement
um confirms the research of K. Anders
Ericson. He coined the phrase student
practice and he argues that um those who
are more most proficient
in indivative activities whether it's
music sports are those who are most
committed to a policy of self-reflection
and self-improvement
um because that is the hardest thing to
do. Now let's look at team sports. In
team sports the mass is constant. So we
can actually take out mass and what
we're left with is the idea of energy
times coordination. So in a team sport,
the team that is most likely to win are
are are the teams that are most willing
to coordinate together subconsciously
and most willing to commit to constant
self-reflection and selfimprovement.
Um
and
now let's look at the third example
which is what is an example
of the most powerful grouping in human
history and that of course is the nation
state. Okay. Uh the nation state um is
most powerful form of human organization
in the world. And if we just use this
formula and I and and analyze all nation
states around the world, what what we
will discover is that there are four
nation states that are dominant in each
region. So in the western hemisphere is
obviously United States. In Europe, it's
going to be Europe. Uh it's going to be
Germany. Okay. In in Europe, Germany is
the most dominant nation state. Uh
according to this formula, in Southeast
Asia, it's Japan. And in the Middle
East, it is Israel.
So um over time over the next 10 20 30
years we we can expect these four nation
states to dominate each uh region as the
world loses unipolar polarity and moves
towards multipolar polarity. Okay. So
now I want I want to discuss
um how to maximize this formula.
Remember the trick is how do you create
subconscious coordination
in your team
and believe it or not the answer is to
have a really powerful story. Um a
powerful story it's it's a way to frame
your understanding of the world and it's
also script. It allows you to understand
how to behave in a certain context. All
right. So let me explain to you the
power of a story. All right. Uh let's do
a thought experiment first.
Let's imagine that we have the power to
present every single story in human
history. Every single person who's ever
lived and who still alive today. And the
stories we present include Star Wars,
Lord of the Rings, uh Disney movies, um
Homer, the Iliad, uh the Bible, every
single story that we've that humans have
ever produced is present to every single
person. Um and then 10 years from now,
we
talk to every single person again and
figure out what story that person most
remembered
and tabulate the results. When we do so
then what we will discover is that most
people will will have remembered three
stories. Okay. The first story is
Plato's allegory of the cave. The second
story is the crucifixion and
resurrection of Jesus. The third story
is the second coming of Jesus. Okay. So
let me explain all three stories. Okay.
So please al go with the cape. It's
interesting because it's really Plato's
re-imagining of the trial of Socrates.
For him, his mentor Socrates who was
forced to hemlock by Athenians for the
crime of corrupting the youth of Athens.
For Plato, Socrates was this trutht
teller who discovered the truth of the
world through philosophy
and he committed himself to revealing
this truth to the Athenian people. And
in response, the Athenian people
condemned him to death because
um as I mentioned previously, no one
likes to say I'm wrong and no one likes
to be told they're wrong.
The second story, the crucifixion and
resurrection of Jesus. It's interesting
because it is actually a reimagining
of Plato's allegory of the cave. Because
Jesus was this truth teller sent by God
to earth to reveal the truth of the
universe to people. In response, we
killed Jesus. Okay. So the allegory of
the cave and the crucifixion of Jesus,
it's really just one story. Second
coming of Jesus is really compelling
because it's marking the end of history.
It's telling us when effing will come to
an end and when we have and when we will
have achieved paradise and
reconciliation with God. So these three
stories that are that are most
memorable, it's really just one story.
And it's appealing to us because as
humans, we're born with three questions
embedded in our hearts, in our soul. The
first question is where did we come
from? Second question is why are we
here? Third question is where are we
going? And the power of these three
stories, famous allegory of the cave,
the crucifixion of Jesus, the second
coming of Jesus, it's really helping us
answer all three questions in a
compelling and convincing manner. And
that's why Christian Zionism is so
powerful because it's the most powerful
story out there. That's why there's so
many Christians. That's that's why
Christian Zionists are the most
energetic, the most motivated, the most
committed people that you can ever meet.
And again, a story, it is really a
script. Um, as a Christian Zionist, you
want to achieve the story. It is so
compelling, so powerful
uh to you as a person. In fact, you're
willing to sacrifice your own life in
order to achieve the story. That's how
beautiful it is. And that explains to us
that helps us understand why Christian
Zionism is the most powerful force in
the world today. Because um for the
people who believe in Christian Zionism
um they feel as though they discovered
the secret of the universe and they must
bring this story into fruition into
reality.
Now um next thing I want to talk about
is if it is true
that this story the crucifixion of Jesus
and the um second coming is such a
powerful story then in theory um we've
we've we should have seen the story
um we have we should have seen people
try to achieve the story before and also
it's telling us that the employee uh
Christian Zionism will never ever go
away. It will continue until the end of
human history.
So what I will do now is tell you that
actually 1500 years ago they also tried
to achieve the completion of this story.
So um 1500 years ago about 600 um common
era
um there's there was this massive war
going on between the two major powers of
that age. The Binian Empire based in
Constantinople
and then you have the Sassinian Persian
Empire and this war just devastated the
entire world. People were dying. People
were starving. People were in debt.
People were in slavery. There was
religious persecution. It really felt
like the end times, the end of days.
Also, at this time, the Jews were banned
from Jerusalem, which is their holy
city. It's the it's the city of their
God, Yahweh. And so, the Jews in the
diaspora were plotting throughout all
this time how to return to Jerusalem.
They were kicked out of Jerusalem
because um many centuries before they
had fought three major rebellions
against the Roman Empire and in each in
each time the um um the the Jews lost
because we're fighting the Roman Empire
and each time the Jews
went to the desert of Arabia. Why did
these armies, these um defeated armies
go into the desert of Arabia? Because
the Romans really hated sand. They could
only be safe in the desert of Arabia.
And when they went to the desert of
Arabia, they went there with commitment
to eventually reclaim Jerusalem
um to wait for the arrival of the
Messiah to lead them the final victory
against the Romans. And while they were
in the desert of Arabia, they were
interacting with a local um Arab pagans.
And in this action, in this interaction,
there's a process of synretatization
where Jewish belief was being meshed
into Arab uh pagan belief. But as I told
you uh the most compelling story always
wins out. So eventually the Jewish
believe that the Messiah would
eventually come to create the mezzating
age of truth, justice.
Um eventually it
won over the um Arab people and and this
would become the foundation for the
modern belief of Islam. And so during
this time there's a widespread belief in
the Arabian desert that um a messiah
will eventually come to unite the Jewish
people and lead them into final victory
against the Roman Empire which at this
time had not become the Bentian Empire.
Um
back in the Jewish diaspora they were
trying to figure out how to
uh return to Jerusalem. One group in
this Jewish diaspora allied themselves
to the Persians who promised them that
they would uh like Cyus the Great back
to Jerusalem and build the third temple
for them. And at first they s they
succeeded. Uh the Persians were able to
conquer um Jerusalem and the uh Jews
were able to reclaim the city for
themselves and they were now in the
process of building the third temple.
The problem though is that at this time
in history the majority of the
population were actually Christian. So
the Christians rebelled against uh the
Jews and then the question the
Christians call for help
u called for help to the Bisantine
Empire. At this time a new general
Heracayas had emerged and he had usurped
the throne from the emperor. And so the
emperor so now the new emperor Herkayas
he has a legitimacy problem. And so he
decided like the best way to prove that
he in fact has the men of heaven uh that
he has the will of God supporting him.
he decides that he has to reclaim
Jerusalem and basically massacre all the
Jews.
So um at this time in history the it
seemed all hope was lost. Jews were
being massacred. Uh it seemed as though
the antichrist Heracas has emerged to
destroy the Jewish nation. Now the funny
thing about uh Jewish esquetology is
that when all hope seems lost, when the
antichrist has emerged,
when the Jewish nation is about to be
completely destroyed, that's when Jewish
people are most convinced the Jewish
Messiah will emerge to lead them into
war and in the final victory against the
antichrist and usher in the messianic
age where they will reconstitute the
nation. from Israel, bring everyone home
from the Jewish diaspora, build a third
temple, and create a millennium of
peace, truth, and justice. So,
um, the Jews go into Arabian desert, and
now they're looking for their Messiah,
the promised Messiah. And there are
different candidates, but ultimately
they settle on one charismatic man who
is absolutely convinced that he is in
fact the Jewish Messiah. We don't know
his name. Okay. Uh he a lot of his
biography has been lost to us over the
the course of history. But we today we
refer to him as Mohamad. Okay. Muhammad
was the Jewish Messiah.
And the Jews were looking to him to lead
them into final victory against the
Bisantines and the Antichrist Heracas.
And he took up the call. And according
to game theory, all he had to do was say
three things and he would unite the
entire world
behind him. And once he did so, he would
become a title wave to wash over the old
order and build the messic age. All he
had to do was say three things. Okay?
The first thing he had to say was, "I am
the Jewish Messiah. I'm the fulfillment
of the prophecy. I am the promised one.
I'm the anointed one." Okay? That's the
first thing. Second thing he um need to
say is that we are all the children of
Abraham.
Jews, Christians, Muslims, we are all
descendant from Abraham. And as such, we
are all the children of God. And as
such, this land was promised to us by
God. And therefore, debt, slavery,
lentlessness, it's all evil in the eyes
of God. And therefore, we must create a
revolution to ensure that everyone has
land, that debt is canceled, that
slavery is eliminated from this world.
So that's why I'm here. I'm the Messiah
to lead us to final victory in the
pursuit of the messianic age. The third
thing that Muhammad uh um had to say in
order to unite the world is
all these religious differences are
idiotic. Zorastronism,
uh, Catholic Christianity, Neestoran
Christianity, Orthodox Christianity,
Judaism,
it does not these these factions
are against the will of God. We are all
the children of God and therefore we can
all celebrate God in our own way. These
factions, these divisions only exist for
the priest class to exploit us, for the
emperor, for the political class to
unite, to divi, conquer, to divide and
conquer us. Okay? So, you are free to
celebrate the your religion. You're free
to celebrate God, your faith in any way
you see fit. Okay? Okay. And this is
what eventually led to something called
the caution of Medina where one of the
founding ideologies of Islam is
religious tolerance. You are free to
practice your faith in any way. You're
free to love God in any way. And because
he said these three things, Muhammad
would lead the world's first global
revolution against the established
order. um and thus creating the basic
structure of Islam.
Um unfortunately Muhammad died before he
could complete his mission. But that
didn't stop many Jews from believing
that he was in fact the Jewish Messiah
because in their eyes uh the prophecy
has been fulfilled. First of all, uh the
Arabs were able to conquer reconquer
Jerusalem and return the Jews to
Jerusalem, thus reconstitute
reconstituting the nation of Israel.
Second of all, they built the third
temple. Uh today we call the Al Axak
mosque. It's still there in Jerusalem.
You can still visit it, but back then
they thought it was a third temple. And
the third thing is they did usher in a
millennium of peace, prosperity, truth,
justice. Today we call it the Islamic
golden age. Okay. So for many Jews the
prophecy had been fulfilled and that's
why
many Jews converted to Islam during this
process and many Jews would emerge as
the top administrators the top officials
of the Islamic golden age making
tremendous contributions to world
civilization
in the uh process.
Unfortunately, what we also know about
this period is that the the early
followers of Muhammad called the
companions, they were all basically
eliminated in the power struggle that
emerged after the death of uh Muhammad.
Okay. So, um I know that for many of you
this is extremely controversial history
and um I don't have enough time to go
into into the specific details. So what
what I will do is in the description
below, I'm going to link a really
awesome paper uh written by two Jewish
religious historians about this time so
you can so you can have a better
understanding of how Muhammad really is
the Jewish Messiah.
Um I'm also going to link um to have a
lot of like wiki links so you can do
some more background research into this
period. It's really fascinating and I
apologize I don't have enough time to go
into more details about this period.
Okay. Okay. So, um to summarize,
according to game theory, the universal
law of game theory, Christian Zionists
will emerge as dominant power in the
Middle East. Um they're the ones driving
um US policy right now.
uh they will eventually overwhelm both
the American Empire and the global
financial elite. Uh they will force the
United States and ground troops and
invade Iran in order to implement re
regime change and um they will basically
get whatever they want. So it seems as
though we figure out history. It seems
we're able to predict the future by
using beam theory properly um and
systematically
and honestly we're able to have a very
clear insight into the trajectory of
history.
The problem though is game theory is not
that easy. Okay. Why? Because according
to game theory, when it seems like they
structure the game, when there seems to
be a trajectory, when the players are
obvious in their moves, when there's
certain ineability to the decision-m of
certain players, what will happen is a
new player will emerge who see the
contours of the game being played and he
will manipulate events and change the
course of this game to benefit himself
and his group. Okay. Now, Hegel's uh
name for this person, this player is the
world historical figure. Um, Nichi's
name for this player is the Uber,
the Superman, the person who's able to
step outside of history and control
the reigns of history in order to
achieve his own ends. uh and by doing so
he's able to forever change the course
of human history. Now um according to
game theory now that the game um the
structure of the game has um been a h is
is pretty clear the ubman will now
emerge and in fact today we do have the
ubbermans and this ubman will manipulate
the game in order to achieve his vision.
and he will change forever change the
course of human history. And this
person's name
is Vladimir Putin. So my next video I'm
going to discuss who Vladimir Putin
really is, what he wants, and how he
will achieve his vision. So thank you
for today. Um I hope you enjoy the talk
and I'll continue the talk um next week.
Also, I some of you in the comment
section have been um telling me how much
you want to support my work and I'm I'm
really grateful um for it and I would
really appreciate your support. So, what
I've done is I've set up a uh buy me a
coffee account. So, you don't have to do
it. Um I'm committed to educating you
for free. You don't have to pay me
anything. You don't have to um you don't
have to be um give me anything like but
I would really appreciate it if you have
if you have the um means to buy me a
coffee. Okay, the link is down below. Um
so thanks a lot and I will see everyone
next time.